[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
من بيجرود الى البوسفور روسيا تصده هجمات
عابره للحدود وبريغوجوشن يعرض فاتوره
باخمه الباهظه من القتلى
في السودان مستقبل البلاد رهينه صراع
الجنراللين تبادل الاتهامات بخرق الهدن
واشتباكات على الارض
اردوغان امام اختيارين اختبار الرئاسه
واختبار وحده حزبه بعد انباء عن الخلافات
داخل العداله والتنميه
[موسيقى]
المنقلب على ترامب يستعد بعد ساعات لاعلان
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه عبر
تويتر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه التصدي لهجوم بحري شنته
الثلاثه زوارق اوكرانيه سريعه مسيره على
سفينه ايفانخور تتابعه لاسطول البحر
الاسود في منطقه مضيق البوسفور وقال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايجور انه تم تدمير
جميع القوارب المعاديه في زمن قياسي مشيرا
الى ان السفينه الروسيه كانت تقوم بحمايه
خطي غاز
في المنطقه الاقتصاديه التركيه واكد ان
السفينه ايفان خورصه تابعه لاسطول البحر
الاسود تواصل اداء مهامها
هذا وتوعد وزير الدفاع الروسيه برد صادم
وصارم على اي محاولات لتوغل مسلحين
اوكرانيين للحدود الروسيه مشيرا الى مقتل
سبعين مسلحا في بيل جرود هذا ونشره تسالوا
الروسيه مقاطع مصوره قالت انها لمركبات
امريكيه الصنع استخدمها المسلحون
الاوكرانيون في الهجوم على منطقه الحدوديه
فذكرت التقارير الروسيه ان المواجهات
تسببت في تضرر 500 منزل على الاقل في بيل
جروت
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلن حاكم منطقه ان سلطات المقاطعه
شكلت سبعه كتائب دفاع تضم نحو ثلاثه الاف
شخص لتامين الحدود مع اوكرانيا واوضح حاكم
السلطات تدرس تسليحه تلك المجموعات مشيرا
الى انها تتدرب منذ نوفمبر الماضي واكد
المسؤول الروسي ان الحاجه لتلك الكتائب
ظهرت بعد الهجوم الاخير على
من موسكو الدكتور رونالد بيجاموف المحلل
السياسي دكتور اهلا بك معنى روسيا اتهمت
ايضا اوكرانيا بمهاجمه سفينه حربيه تابعه
لها تقوم بدوريه في المياه الاقليميه
التركيه هل انتقلت الهجمات الاوكرانيه الى
خارج الحدود الروسيه
[موسيقى]
الروسيه في المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه
التركيه بالقربه
كيف كيف يعني اذا تكرر الامر يعني كنا
نتحدث عن الحدود الروسيه على بلده بيل
غرود الان نتحدث على السفينه الروسيه في
المياه التركيه ماذا لو تكرر الامر ماذا
ستفعل روسيا
يبدو ان موسى هذه الحجمات سوف تتكرر في
الخدود الروسيه ويجبل روسيا ان تتخذوا
الاجراءات اما فيما يتعلق تركيا هناك ايضا
نقطه مهمه كل هذا يحدث
قبيل الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
التركيه ويبدو انها الرساله ليس فقط الى
روسيا باستخدام خطوط الانابيب الغاز كما
تم استخدام سابقا للنور ستريم في بحر
البلطيق ولكن هذه الاشاره ايضا
بالنسبه
هو
الشريك الاريخ اذا اذا يفوز في الانتخابات
التركيه وهذه الرساله فاتتها اوكرانيا
ايضا الى تركيا لان الحدث هو وقع في
المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخاصه التركيه ويبدو
انه تم
اخداء السفن التي تمر عبران ممر الحبوب
اما كان لانه من الصعب ارسال هذه الزوارق
المسيره من الساحل الاوكراني يبدو انها تم
نقل الزوارق علمتني
في كل حال من الاحوال الروس نجحوا اليوم
وصدوا هذا الهجوم
ولكن لا اخذ يستطيع ان يستبعد تكرار مثل
هذه الحجمات وفي المستقبل لان الايمان
امثل هذه الحجمات ينبغي على روسيا ان
تسيطروا على شمال الساخن البحر الاسود كله
يعني الاستيلاء المدن الاوكرانيه مثل
اوتيسا والقائد العسكريه البحريه الشهيره
اسماعيل على نهر دانوب
الحل الوحيد اما يجب ان ناخذ فيها
الاعتبار ان المس الهذه الهجمات سوف تتكرر
ساعود اليك ارجو ان تبقى معنا ساعود اليك
في زاويه اخرى من ملف هذا الصراع الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ميدانيه المشاهدين كشف قائد
قوات روسيه عن مقتل نحو عشره الاف سجين تم
تجنيدهم للقتال مع قواته في اوكرانيا
واوضحت بريغوجين انه جنند 50 الف سجين قتل
20% منهم وقتل العدد ذاته من المتطوعين في
فاجنر بمعارك ضخمه مشيرا الى ان الخسائر
الاوكرانيه في المدينه اكثر باضعاف
على مدار العمليات جنته 50 الف سجين قتل
منهم حوالي 20% وقتل العدد ذاته من
المتعاقدين معنا بالاضافه الى نحو 20% من
الجرحى والذين اصيبوا ولا يستطيعون القيام
بالمهام القتاليه خلال الاشهر المقبله تم
القضاء على ما يقارب من 50 الى 70 الف
مقاتل من القوات الاوكرانيه ولديهم اصابات
بما يعادل 300 الف وذلك لان اجلاءهم كان
صعبا
قبل ان نتابع مع ضيفنا نشير فقط الى
العالم الجيل تايمز استقل ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يبحث ارسال 196 مليار يورو من
اصول روسيا المجاوده المجمده لصالح
اوكرانيا دكتور رولاند اعود اليك لاسالك
عن المغزى من كلام
قائد مجموعه عن خسائره في المعارك
الاوكرانيه
يتحدث ويدلي بهذه التصريحات في اطار
حملاته المضاده لوزاره الدفاع هو ينتقد
وزاره الدفاع بشده وخاصه وزير الدفاع
هناك تناقضات شهيد كبيره ظهرت في الاشهر
الاخيره بسبب نقص الذخيره نقص امداد هذه
الزهيره لقوات بريوجن لشركه
الان تحول الى
كبير في روسيا وخطي قد يسبق شخصيه سياسيه
كبيره على الرغم من انه هو نفسه ينفع ينفي
ذلك ولكن الحديث يصل الى حتى امكانيه ان
يرشخ نفسه كاهخذ مرشحين
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله في
اذن اليوم
فقط قائد عسكري ناجحون بل تحول الى
الرمس السياسي
لكن دكتور هذا يدفعني كي اسال يعني لانه
تحدث كذلك على الوضع
الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا وقال ان
الحدود هذه لا تحظى بالحمايه المناسبه في
اشاره للهجمات الاوكرانيه على بيل جرود هل
تعتقد ان روسيا بعد نجاحات فاجنر ستستخدم
فاجنر اكثر او ربما ستستخدم فاينر للرد
على اوكرانيا بخصوص هذه الهجمات على
اراضيها
المتواضعه للوطن
التجهد روسيا
لمصاده الوغر وتم استضافه من افريقيا في
في
العام الماضي بعدما ادركت القياده
العسكريه الروسيه والقياده السياسيه ايضا
بانه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه لا تجري
وفقا للخطى وطلبوا المصادر
من افريقيا وصل في خلال ثلاثه ايام مع
قواته ودخل في المعركه وكان ناجح في هذه
القطاع الذي كلف اليه وكان يقوم هناك
بالعمليات في سوليدار وبعد ذلك حارب هذه
المعركه
باخموت مفرق باخموت كما يقال وخقق اهدافه
ونجح فيه بالفعل
السيطره على المدينه
ولكن لا اعتقد انه يتم الاستغناء
وفي نفس الوقت لا اعتقد ان الجيش الروسي
يعني لا يشارك في المعركه وسيكون وفقد
والشركات الخاصه تخاربه هو ليس كذلك
خاصه القوات الخاصه
مثل الخبراء العسكريين والسابقين من زاويه
الخبره
بالفعل الناس متمرسين جدا
وشاركوا في الحروب ويتم استخدامهم كقوات
الاقتحام
وهي جيده جدا في القطار في شواريا
والاستيلاء على المدن وتدريب العسكريين
تنفيذ غيرها من المهام العسكريه باحثه
وكذلك مهام الامن والخراسه شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور رولاند بيجام وفا المحلل الاساسي
كنت معنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نذهب الان الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان الديمقراطيون يقدمون اجازه
فيما يتعلق بالمفاوضات الخاصه
برفع سقف الدين الامريكي
خلال هذه الفتره 25% من ديون الدوله تم
تراكمت خلال رئاسه الرئيس ترامب
حدث ذلك ثلاثه مرات
وتعاونت تعاون مجلس النواب الديمقراطي مع
الرئاسه
رئاسه لضمان ان لا تتخلف امريكا عن سداد
ديونها
لماذا اختلفت الامور الان
لماذا
يتبنى الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب هذا
الموقف المتطرف وغير العقلاني المؤسف انه
يمكن فقط ليس درسا واحدا
على الشفاء تخلف عن السداد
ان الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب عقدون العزمه
على اما
التسبب او خفض كبير سيؤثر على رعايه
وسلامه المواطنين الامريكيين او يتسبب ذلك
بانهيار الاقتصاد من خلال التخلف عن سداد
الديون وهذا ما سيؤدي الى حاله ركود مؤلمه
هذا هم الخياران
اللذان يراهم الجمهوريون في مجلس نواب
اعتبارهما
السبيلان الوحيدان
اللذان يمكن ان نسلكهم
وهذا يعود طبعا لموقف الرئيس السابق ترامب
وهذا طبعا ايضا ما سيؤدي الى
الالم
المواطن الامريكيين
ان الامريكيين يدركون ان الجمهورين في
مجلس النواب يرغبون في تحقيق احد الهدفين
وتسبب بانخفاضات كبيره سوف تؤثر على صحه
وسلامه ورفاهيه المواطنين الامريكيين
والمحاربين القدامى والمعوقين وكذلك
المدرسين
والمستفيدين من الرعايه الاجتماعيه واولئك
الامريكي الذي يحتاجون للمساعده في مجال
التغذيه او اتسبب بالتخلف عن سداد الديون
والكثير من الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
اوضحوا مواقفهم انهم عاقدون العزمه
لتسبب بانهيار الاقتصاد انهم يعتقد ان هذا
سيفيدهم سياسيين هذا هو الشرح الوحيد لهذا
الموقف
المتشدد وغير العقلاني
عقل كلمه الان الى كاترين كلارك
شكرا السيد زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس نحن هنا على شافه
الكارثه اقتصاديه هذه الكارثه ستؤدي الى
خساره ثمانيه ملايين وظيفه لماذا لان
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب قد قرروا الدفع
امريكا للتخلف عنه السدود دعونا السداد
دعونا نوضح الامور هذه معركه بين التطرف
والعقلانيه منذ البدايه
قدم البيت الابيض حلول عقلانيه
والرئيس وافق على ميزانيه تعمل على خدمه
مصالح الاسر وخفض العجز بثلاثه
تريليون دولار لكن الجمهورين انتظروا
لتسبب بتخلف عني السادات وكذلك
طلبوا بخفض كبير
لمساعدات التي تقدم
للمواطنين الامريكيين الضعفاء وكذلك
المحاربين القدامى والاطفال وغيرهم
هذا الامر ليس بالطبيعي
وانما هذا وضع يتسم باخذ امريكا كرهينه
واعترف بان الامر الجمهوريين
يدركون بان هناك حاجه
للتفاوض مع من يتسبب بهذا الوضع
وهناك موقف متشدد ومن لديه من قام بهذه
العمليه ليس البيت الابيض ولا الكونجرس
ولا الديمقراطي وانما الامريكيون
انهم يرغبون من المواطنين الامريكيين ان
يقوموا بخيار صعب اما التخفيض الكبير
وتسبب بالتخلف عن السداد الديون اخراج
الاطفال من مراكز الرعايه
الصحيه او
تتسبب بخسارته اولياء امورهم وظائفهم
هذا لا يتعلق بالدين والامر لا يتعلق
بالانفاق ما هو الدليل على ذلك وكما قال
زعيم الديمقراطيين الجمهوريه تسبب
بالديون دولار
[موسيقى]
وفي الوقت ذاته
من هذا المؤتمر الصحفي او هذا الايجاز
للاقليه الديمقراطيه ايضا في
في مجلس النواب الامريكي والحديث عن مدى
تقدم المفاوضات مع الجمهوريين لرفع سقف
الدين الامريكي وطبعا الديمقراطيون
الاتهامات للجمهوريين بانهم يحاولون دفع
امريكا الى التخلف عن السداد سداد ديونها
[موسيقى]
والى الملف السوداني الان حيث اطلق الجيش
السوداني وقذائفه من منطقه المهندسين
باتجاه تمركز قوات الدعم السريع هذا
وتتواصل الاشتباكات بين طرفي الصراع وتزيد
حدتها في اندرمان وافادت انباء سودانيه
بان قوات الدعم السريع تتاهب لشن هجوم على
مواقع الجيش في محيط منطقه المهندسين
رغم المسائل الرميه الى وقف اطلاق النار
في السودان الى ان المشهد لم يتغير من
خلال استمرار القتال بين طرفي الصرع اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار الاخير اجهض تماما كما
حدث مع اتفاقيات الهدنه التي سبقتها
الطرفان لم يصل لاي ارضيه للتفاهم من اجل
ايجاد حل سلمي للازمه التي اندلعت قبل
ازيد من شهر فلماذا يا ترى لم تنجح جهود
الوساطه في اقناع الطرفين باحترام
اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار للاجابه على هذا
السؤال يجب الانتباه الى ان الاتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار الاخير كان الهدف منه انساني
فقط وهذا يعكس الرفض التام لكلا الطرفين
في فتح مفاوضات للتوصل الى اتفاق سياسي
كما ان الطرفين معا لم يبديا اي ليونه في
المفاوضات في ظل التشبت كل واحد منهما
بموقفه واتهام الطرف الاخر بالتسبب في
الاز مه يضاف الى ذلك عجز الاحزاب المدنيه
في التدخل للوساطه في ظل ضعف علاقتها
بالطرفين
الخطر الاكبر المحدق بالبلاد الان هو ان
تزلق السودان الى حرب الى مسارات اكثر
فداحا كما ان غياب الاستقرار داخل البلاد
قد يدفع المدنيين الى التسلح للدفاع عن
انفسهم ما قد يتسبب في انتشار الاسلحه في
البلاد هذا ويبقى سيناريو اندلاعي حرب
اهليه هو التهديد الاخطر على الاطلاق
والتي قد تندلع في حال استهداف جماعات
عرقيه بعينها
ومهما كان المسار الذي ستاخذه المعارك فان
المدنيين هم الضحيه الاكبر بهذا الخصوص
قالت منظمه الامم المتحده ان المدنيين
يعانون من المعارك المتواصله واصفه للوضع
الانساني بالماساوي اوضح الذات المنظمه ان
الاشتباكات اسفرت عن مقتل 850 مدنيا فضلا
عن اصابه 3500 شخص ونزوح مئات الالاف
وقالت المنظمه الامميه دائما ان الاطراف
المتقاتله تنتهك جميع حقوق الانسان مشيره
الى ان المدنيين باتوا يعانون من نقص
الادويه كما اكدت تعرضا العديد من المنازل
للنهب مشيره في الوقت نفسه الى وجود نقص
في المياه والطعام
معنا من القاهره لواء بابكر ابراهيم
الخبير العسكري ولواء السابق في القوات
الجويه دكتور اهلا بك معنا لماذا يتم خرق
الهدن بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا التحيه لك
ولمشاهدينك اولا يجب ان نسمن على دور
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في اليه
ويجب ان نشير الى ان الشعب السوداني يؤمن
الكثير بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
خاصه وان السودان والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه يؤمنون باجراءات عمل وتعليمات
عمل الربانيه في هذا الخصوص اسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى يقول فان طائفه تعني من
المؤمنين اقتتلوا فاصلحوا بينهما ان بغيت
احداهما الاخرى فغاتل التي تبقى حتى انت
في الله اذا نحن نعمل من السعوديه ان تكون
هي الفيصل بين الاخوه المتقاتلين
هذا يجب ان نؤكده في البدء لكن بوجود هذه
المعادله الربانيه المعروفه الا ان
الشعب السوداني قد تفاجا في نفس التوقيت
التي الذي تدعو فيه
المجموعه السعوديه
والامريكيه الى
التهدئه
خطاب ومنسوب الى الفريق او حميتي يدعو فيه
مقاتليه الى
الثبات والقتال ومواصله القتال وعدم
التراجع هذا كان خيبه امل بالنسبه
للسودانيين كرد فعل اولي من غايه هذه
المجموعات على مستوى اعاده على المقاطعه
يعني طبعا كل طرف يحمل الطرف الاخر
مسؤوليه خرق الهدنه ولكن دعنا نذهب لنرى
ابعد من ذلك هل ترى مخرجا لهذه الازمه ما
شكل المخرج كيف ترى نهايه هذه المواجهه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في السودان ام لا
تراها ابدا
المخرج واضح هنالك
طرفان يدعوان الى التهدئه والى المفاوضات
هذه يجب ان تكون هنالك اهليه لتحدد الفئه
الباقيه وهذه الفئه الباقيه يجب ان تغاتل
حتى تفيد الى امر الله هذا امر رباني
فانفاءه نرجع تاني لصلح هذا هو المخرج
الرباني الواضح كاجراد عمله تعليمات عمل
ربانيه
خلال 24 ساعه الفائته
القوات المسلحه رصدت 72 خرق بالنسبه لقوات
الدعم السريع بدءا من اعاده التموضع اذا
حركت قوات الدعم السريع بطاريات المدفعيه
الى الجهه الشرقيه من النيل
لتشكل تهديد لقاعده وادي سيدنا الجويه
القاعده التي يتمركز فيها
المقاتلات هذا على مستوى
العسكري على المستوى الاقتصادي ما زالت
قوات العامه السريع تنهب في
البنوك وتسرق في مقتنيات الاسر
والتروع الاسر على المستوى الاجتماعي
القوات الدعم السريع استولد على
مستشفيين اضافيين لجمله المستشفيات التي
تتمركز فيها اما الترويع المواطنين عذرا
على المقاطعه الوقت اعتذر منك شكرا جزيلا
لك سياده اللواء بابا بكر ابراهيم انتم
الخبير العسكري السابق في القوات الجويه
شكرا جزيلا لك
تبينت المشاهدات في السودان في اليوم
الثاني من الهدنه مواطنون وجدوا فيه
متنفسا للعوده لحياتهم الطبيعيه او
لاعمالهم فيما شهد اخرون على خرق الهدنه
وسماع اصوات المدافع وسط ترقب لعقوبات
تعهد بها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي حاله
ثابته خرق الهدنه هدنه سبعه ايام المتفق
عليها
في هدنه السبعه ايام هذا احد شوارع ام
درمان عوده مؤقته للحياه ربما وفرصه
للجلوس في اجواء هادئه نسبيا لا يتخللها
اصوات الحرب
اما هنا ففرصه ايضا لكسب الرزق وجوله عمل
حرم منها لشهر واكثر
بينما هذه السيده وجدت متنفسا بعد صراع
اسقاها مراره الحاجه
شيء من اساسيات الحياه عادت متواضعه هنا
وفي المنازل انفراجه ايضا من الهدنه بدات
امس نحن امس الحمد لله الكهرباء رجعت
انقطع كهرباء
وغيرها
العرس لانه بيقول لك الكهرباء والمويه
الحمد لله اليوم الثالث والحمد لله هذا
لكن في حذر شديد يعني
عوده بحذر تفاؤل عام قابله سكان اخرون
شهدوا على خرق للهدنه بسماعهم لاصوات
المدافع بعد التحسب
خشن الرعب فينا وفي اولادنا
وخلونا زي ما احنا هدنه ان ثبتت هشاشتها
سيواجه طرفان نزاع عقوبات امريكيه توعد
بها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في حال لم
يلتزم باتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
غيداء السالم العربي
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
اردوغان امام اختبارين اختبار الرئاسه
واختبار وحده حزبه بعد انباء عن خلافات
داخل العداله والتنميه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قبل ايام من انتخابات
الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
حدث خلاف داخل حزب رجب طيب اردوغان بشان
التمسك بما يسميه البعض برنامجا اقتصاديا
غير مستداا بحسب وكاله رويتس حيث اجتمعت
مجموعه غير رسميه من اعضاء الحزب الحاكم
في الاسابيع الاخيره لمناقشه كيفيه تبني
سياسه جديده لرفع اسعار الفائده تدريجيا
وافدت مصادر مطلعه لوكاله اردوغان ليس
مشاركا بشكل مباشر في المحادثات التي تشمل
بعض اعضاء حزب العداله والتنميه ومن جهه
اخرى هناك مسؤولون واعضاء لمجلس الوزراء
صرحوا علنا انهم يريدون التمسك بالبرنامج
الحالي لتعزيز الصادرات والنمو الاقتصادي
لا يزال خبر تاييد المرشح الرئاسي سنان
اوغان لرجب طيب اردوغان يثير نقاشا واسعا
داخل تركيا فتحالف الرجلين طرح سؤالا
صريحا حول طبيعه التنسيق والتعاون بينهما
في الفتره المقبله سيناريوهات عديده تطرح
حول طبيعتها هذا التعاون في حال فوز
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ويبدو من غير المستبعد وجود
اوغان في الحكومه المقبله التي سيشكلها
اردوغان وقد يصل الامر الى حد تسليمه منصب
نائب الرئيس وهو ما كان يسعى اليه كما ان
التوافق بين الرجلين يعني ضمنيا التركيز
على ملف ترحيل اللاجئين السوريين من تركيا
وقد يستجيب فعلا اردوغان الى طلب اوغان
بانشاء وزاره طوارئ بهدف التعجيل في عمليه
اعاده اللاجئين وعلى الارجح فان اردوغان
سيسرع الى وضع خطط زمنيه لاعاده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلادهم وهو ما صرح به بشكل
علني في العديد من المناسبات
هذا وقال سوريون اعيدوا من تركيا الى
بلادهم انهم واجهوا معامله قاسيه خلال
اقامتهم هناك وعبر عدد منهم التقتهم
العربيه في ريف ادلب شمال سوريا عن
استيائهم من طريقه ترحيلهم واعادتهم الى
البلاد رغم امتلاكهم الوثائق التركيه
الرسميه
وانا تم ترحيلي لهوني انا املك الهويه
التركي لحمايه مؤقته وشالوني بالغلط يعني
فانا كنت احكي معهم للبوليس انه انا معي
كملي معي كملك ما يردوا علي
وتم ترحيله لسوريا يعني بس عم يستنوا
السوري بس اي غلط صغير لحتى بس يرحلون مع
انه انا كمان
وكملك واوراقي كلها قانونيه بالنسبه
للعموري يعني نحن لو ما اهلنا اللي برا
واخواتنا في تركيا نحن هون ما عنا شي ناكل
ولا عنا شي نشربه لاني ما عندنا شيء نعيش
منه عنصريه
كتير كتير كتير يعني
ما بخلونا نتنفس
على هذه اللوحه كتب السوريون سيرحلون
والقرار التخي
قرار يبدو ان المعارضه التركيه ليست وحدها
من انفردت به بل الحزب الحاكم ايضا قرار
اصبح اشبه بسباق مع الزمن شماعته اللاجئون
السوريون
فوفقا لوزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاووش
هوجلو فان تركيا قررت انشاء لجنه اعداد
خارطه طريق لتطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا
وسوريا احد اهدافها اعاده اللاجئين الذين
وصلوا الى تركيا من مناطق سيطره النظام
الى تلك المناطق اللجنه وفقا لتشاووش
اوغلو ستضم ممثلين عن روسيا وايران وتركيا
وسوريا وستعمل على وضع خارطه طريق للتطبيق
اضافه لتشكيل لجنه خاصه بملف عوده
اللاجئين يعقبها اجراء مفاوضات لاعاده
السوريين ممن قدموا من المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها الحكومه السوريه
قبل ايام من الحسم الرئاسي حسب المتنافسون
تحالفاتهم ومواقفهم تحالفات تقول الانباء
ان هدفها الابرز هو ترحيل سوري
فوفقا للتحالفات الجديده جميعها متفقه على
ترحيل السوريين من اقصى اليمين حزب الظفر
بقياده اوميت اوزدا واشد المعادين على
المهاجرين واللاجئين اعلن دعمه لمنافس
اردوغان كما الكليجدار اوغلو بينما اعلن
سنان اوغن القومي المتشدد والمناهض لوجود
اللاجئين في تركيا دعم اردوغان في المرحله
المقبله وبين هذا وذاك ليس من المعلوم من
سيحسم السباق القادم لكن الاكيد ان الجميع
اتفقوا على ترحيل السوري
حتى من وعد بغير ذلك رائد المصطفى العربيه
وعلى الرغم من الضجه التي خلفها تاييد
اوغامي اردوغان الا ان اختياره هذا كان
مرجحا فاغامي يطمح للحصول على منصب حكومي
كما صرح بذلك مرارا وبالتالي فان تاييده
لاردوغان صاحب الصداره في الجوله الاولى
يعطيه فرصا او فرد كما ان اوغامي ينحدر
اصلا من حزب الحركه القوميه الموجوده في
التحالف الحاكم بالاساس
وفي هذا الخضم يبدو ان تاييد اوغان
لاردوغان لا يعني بان الاخيره سيستفيد من
جميع اصوات اوغان في الجوله الثانيه بهذا
الخصوص ذكر صحيفه الامريكيه ان سنان اوغان
لا يملك اي جهاز حزبي لتعبئه مؤيديه سيما
بعد التفكك تحالف الاجداد الذي يمثله مع
نهايه الجوله الاولى كما ذكرت ان هناك
العديد من الناخبين الذين صوتوا لسنان
اوغان في الجوله الاولى لم يكونوا ضمن
مؤيديه في المقام الاول ولكنهم صوتوا له
اعتراضا على ترشح اردوغان وكلج دارولو وما
يعزز هذا الطرح هو استطلاع الاجره صحيفه
زمان التركيه والذي اظهر ان 1.25 من حوالي
الخمسه بالمئه التي حصل عليها اوغان في
الجوله الاولى ستتجه الى اردوغان مقابل
1.8 فقط ستتجه الى
المتوقع ان يمتنع نحو 2% عن المشاركه في
الجوله الثانيه
[موسيقى]
منافسه المحتدمه تلوح في الافق داخل الحزب
الجمهوري مواجهه سيكون طرفاها رئيس
الجمهوري السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم ولايه
فلوريدا
فصديق الامس يتحول رسميا الى خصم لدود
ينافس على بطاقه الترشح داخل الحزب خبر
ترشيح ليس بالمفاجئ فاحتماليه ترشيحه لا
حتى في الافق منذ مده ليست بالقصيره لكن
اللافت في الموضوع هو طريقه الاعلان عن
هذا الترشح والتي ستتم لاول مره عبر منصه
تويتر خلال حوار مع مالك المنصه ايلون
ماسك
نجح ايضا في لفت الانتباه من خلال الطريقه
اختارها للاعلان عن ترشحه ليكون اعلانا
غير مسبوق يحدث للمره الاولى على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وسيجري ماسك مقابله مع
ليسانس على تويتر سبيسز وهي منصه
للمحادثات الصوتيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع واحد من اغنى اغنياء العالم ومتابعين
فاقع عددهم المئه واربعين مليونا قرر حاكم
ولايه فلوريدا روند مشاركه منصه تويتر مع
ايلون ماسك لاعلان ترشحه لانتخابات
الرئاسه الامريكيه
قرار راه البعض غير تقليدي ان لم يكن
غريبا ففي العاده الاهتمام الاعلامي
والجماهري يتركز على شخصيه المرشح الذي
يسوق نفسه للناخب وليس على شخصين يتقاسمان
المنصه
[تصفيق]
اعتقد ان ديسانتس يشعر ان هذا سيمكنه من
الوصول الى جمهور وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الواسع فهو يريد تجاوز وسائل الاعلام
التقليديه مثل سي ان ان وغيرها من وسائل
الاعلام التي جعلها عدوا لها ثانيا فهو
يرى ايلون ماسك شخصيه مؤثره بشكل متزايد
بين المفكرين المحافظين
يطرح نفسه كمرشح الجمهوريين التقليديين
فكحاكم لولايه فلوريدا وقع ديسنتس على عدد
من القرارات التنفيذيه التي تحرم الاجهاض
بعد سته اسابيع وتعادي المهاجرين
والمثليين والانفاق الحكومي لذا فهو يحاول
استماله مؤيدي الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كمرشح محافظ دون متاعب ترامب القانونيه
وشخصيته الجدليه المنفره احيانا للناخب
المستقل
سيكون قادرا على تسويق نفسه على انه
دونالد ترامب لكن بدون دراما لكن المشكله
تكمن في انه يريد ان يكون دونالد ترامب
كذلك لكن بدون القدره على تنشيط
المهرجانات الانتخابيه قاعده الحزب
الجمهوري ليست مع ديسانس حتى الان
وبالتالي فان المشكله التي نراها بالنسبه
له هي كيف يمكنه الحصول على الزخم
استطلاعات الراي تضع في المقدمه بفارق
يتجاوز الثلاثين نقطه عن خصمه لكن هذا قد
يتغير مع بدايه انطلاق الحملات الانتخابيه
ودعم الممولين لذا يخشى ترامبس اكثر من اي
مرشح وبدا ينعته باسم
التقليل من شانه
بعد الاعلان الرسميه سيبدا ديسانتس بعقد
مهرجانات انتخابيه في جميع الولايات خطابه
سيكون يمنيا محافظا لاستماله الاصوات
المتشدده في الحزب الجمهوري قبل ان يتوجه
الى مناخب المستقل في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
امام الرئيس بايدن هذا طبعا اذا استطاع ان
ينتصر على الرئيس السابق دونالدو العربيه
معنا من صفره دكتور احمد بن نافع استاذ
والهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه سان خصيه
الحكوميه دكتور اهلا بك معنا لماذا اخترع
حاكم فلوريدا دوس اعلان ترشحه للرئاسه عبر
تويتر
الاختيار ذكي من عده نواحي اولا من ناحيه
انه هذه الطريقه يتفق فيها على ترامب او
يحاول يتفوق ترامب في في الشيء الترامب
يعني دائما هو يعني بيتعامل معه بشكل
مستمر واللي هي التواصل الاجتماعي ثانيا
انه في 140 مليون متابع
يعني نسبه كبيره منهم حيتابعوا هذا
الاجتماع او هذه المقابله فهي فهي ضربه
على عده مستر احمد هنا عندي سؤال من شقين
يعني ترامب لم يبقى على تويتر هو يستخدم
وشيء اخر هل ما زالت تويتر بالفعل فعال
مازال مؤثرا في توجيه الراي العام
الامريكي
واحد من يعني من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر اللي هو بيستخدم بالصحفيين بيستخدم
باصحاب الراي يعني له تاثير يعني لا مؤثرا
تعتقد نعم نعم
طيب نذهب الى
دونالد ترامب الذي يعني ما يزال مصرا على
استخدام منصته تروس سوشل هل ترى انه ممكن
دسانتس يخطف منه الاضواء لانه ترامب شاطر
جدا في مساله يسلط الاضواء عليه في كل مره
هل نجح دسانتس هذه المره في ان يخطف
الاضواء منه عبر اجراء الاعلان عبر الحوار
مع ايلون ماسك على تويتر
لا هي ليست مؤثره لكن اللي مؤثر ان الناس
بتنقل صور منها على تويتر فهو لما يرسل
تغريده مثلا فمن نجدها على تويتر يعني
موجوده ومنتشره منتشره بشكل كبير نعم طيب
[موسيقى]
سيدخل هذه المعركه للفوز بالترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري معركه يتوقع ان تكون طاحنه مع
دونالد ترامب برايك من الاكثر براعه هنا
في توظيف السوشيال ميديا او وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وهل فعلا يمكن ان تكون منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي هي الفيصل في فوز اي من
الرجلين بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه
هو دائما يعني اكثر واحد يعرف كيف يستخدم
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هو كان في
التلفزيون ورجل وباع طويل في يعني في هذا
المجال فما في احد يكون قريب منه حتى يشوف
الاستطلاع اللي ذكرتوه في التقرير انه
الفرق بينه وبين 30 نقطه وما قدر حتى يقرب
منه بالطريق هذه فاذا هي المساله المساله
التواصل الاجتماعي
هو هو يعني الماستر السيد في الموضوع هذا
ويعرف كيف يستخدمها نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
عبر سكايب كنت معنا من دكتور احمد بن نافع
استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه سانخ
الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
فاصل نواصل بعده واخبر الساعه يبقى معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت صور لقمر صناعيين
امريكيه عن قيام الصين بارسال مسيره
متطوره لقاعده عسكريه في شرق الصين هذا
الامر اثار المخاوف حول عمل الصين على حشد
قدراتها العسكريه قبيل هجوم المحتمل على
جزيره تايوان
طائره بدون طيار صينيه تفوق سرعه الصوت
تستخدم لعمليات الرصد والتجسس
كشفت عنها الصين عام 2019
قادره على القيام بالتجسس الاستراتيجي
مداها يسمح لها بالوصول لتايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
ارسلتها بكين لقاعده الوان العسكريه
القاعده تقع في محافظه الوان شرقي البلاد
على مسافه قصيره
تم تعديل المدرج لكي يستقبل المسيره
المتطوره في الاسابيع الاخيره قامت مسيرات
صينيه بالطيران حول الجزيره هدف العمليه
كان اثبات قدرات بكين على التجسس ورصد
الاهداف التايوانيه لتوجيه ضربات صاروخيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت السلطات المكسيكيه ان بركان بوبوا
الواقع على بعد سبعين كيلو مترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه واصل قد فرماد وغازات وقذف
البركان البالغ ارتفاعه
5,426 مترا مواد متوهجه تشبه الحمم
البركانيه الحمراء لكن مستوى التحذير من
اقطاره لا يزال على حاله اي اقل بخطوه
واحده من درجه الخطر القص
[موسيقى]
بهذا تنتهي اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله
تذكير بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
من البوسفور روسيا تصدها هجمات عابره
للحدود
يعرض فاتوره ضخمه الباهظه من القتله
في السودان مستقبل البلاد رهينه صراع
الجنرلين تبادل الاتهامات بخرق الهدى
واشتباكات على الارض
عرض غانا امام اختبارين اختبار الرئاسه
واختبار وحده حزبه بعد انباء عن خلافات
داخل العداله والتنميه
حاكم فلوريدا المنقلب على ترامب يستعد بعد
ساعات لاعلان ترشحه للانتخابات الامريكيه
عبر تويتر
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت هذه اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله
شكرا لكم على اكرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
العربيه على صفحاتنا على مواقع التواصل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات